is the proportion true or false that 3
12 or 3 to 12 is equal to 5 35 or 5
to 35 now to figure this out we just
have to figure out whether these are
equivalent fractions and the easiest way
to do that is to put both of them in
simplified form and see if we get the
same answer so let's try with 3 12 first
so if we have 3 over 12 both of these
are divisible both the numerator and the
denominator are divisible by 3 so let's
divide by 3 so divide the numerator by 3
and let's divide the denominator by 3
and we get 3 divided by 3 is 1
12 divided by 3 is 4. so 3 12 is the
same thing as 1 4. now let's try to do
the same thing for five thirty-fifths
five
over thirty-five leaving some space so
we can divide well these are both
divisible by five so let's divide the
numerator and the denominator by five
so if we divide the numerator by 5 and
the denominator by 5 the numerator 5
divided by 5 is 1
and then 35 divided by 5 is 7. so this
thing is equivalent to saying that 1 4
one-fourth is equal to one-seventh which
is clearly which is clearly not true
this is clearly not true so the
proportion
is false